On your math quiz, you earn
5 points for each question
that you answer correctly.
In the table below, x represents
the number of questions
that you answer correctly, and
y represents the total number
of points that you
score on your quiz.
Fair enough?
The relationship between
these two variables
can be expressed by the
following equation--
y is equal to 5x.
Graph the equation below.
So you could look at a
couple of your points.
You could say, well, look,
if I got 0 questions right
I'm going to have 0 points.
So you could literally
graph that point--
if I got 0 questions
right, I get 0 points.
And then if I get
one question right,
and the table tells us
that, or we could logically
think about it, every
question I would get right
I'm going to get 5 more points.
So if I get one question right,
I'm going to get 5 more points,
and we saw that in
our table as well.
We saw that right over here--
one question, 5 points.
We could also plot it
two questions, 10 points,
any of these.
But you only have to do two
points to define a line.
So it looks like we
are actually done here.